the end of the Harry Potter saga
actually kind of said Harry Potter and
the Deathly Hallows part-2
alright so well my Deathly Hallows Part
1 review I said that that movie was the
build-up to the climax and part two was
just gonna be Armageddon and I was right
after the first scene before the title
of Deathly Hallows part-2 I was like
dude I'm diggin the tone of this movie I
was in at that point
so Deathly Hallows part-2 picks up right
where Part 1 left off and still as Alice
Cooper once said school's out forever
well not forever but they're still out
hunting Horcruxes so they can take them
out the stake out Lord Voldemort I'm
gonna like about definitely Hallows
part-2 is it put you right into it I
mean they have one mission to do and
it's really exciting and then after that
they head to Hogwarts for the big
showdown and I gotta say when they go to
Hogwarts and they're all setting up for
the big finale and they're casting their
spells and everyone's getting into place
for battle I was like dude this is
awesome
and from there till the end of the movie
it's Armageddon with magic I mean all
the characters from Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone they're all grown up
now and they're all fighting in a war
and yeah they have their arsenal of
spells and they're all a bunch of little
badass kids or you know adults now I'm a
big fan of the Harry Potter books and I
tried to watch this movie and not
compare it to the book too much because
I know movies take artistic license
there were a couple things that they
left out that I would have liked to have
seen in the movie but you can pass those
off as details but ultimately when
you're reading the book you hit that
point where you're like dude just like
4:00 a.m. I got to go to bed but I can't
put it down pretty much 3/4 of this
movie is from that point on I gotta say
the main Throwdown like the war at the
end of this movie is pretty much exactly
how I pictured it I'm at the
cinematography and the music going with
it I couldn't have asked for more so
every port in the book where you were
like oh my god that just happened is
probably in this movie there were a
couple of things where I was like I wish
they would have polish that a bit I'm
not gonna spoil too much for you but you
know it's the final chapter it's war you
know people you know can get hurt and
you don't even see it happen you see the
aftermath like oh you know that sucks
no build-up no epic music just kind of
happened yeah happened it's in past
tense you don't even see it if there was
a part where I would have liked the
movie to take artistic license it would
have been in those scenes and there will
be people who will complain they'll be
like oh this movie doesn't have any
character building it's just a lot of
battles well they do have character
building it's called Deathly Hallows
Part 1 in the previous 6 movies this
movie's exactly what it needs to be and
that is the fulfilling conclusion of a
10-year epic of movies 7 years for the
in the movie 10 for us I mean this fight
is so huge that everyone really gets
their piece of the action hero of the
day the underdog of the world Neville
Longbottom
boy someone I know something Neville
Longbottom poster and he was like why is
that guy in the poster I was like dude
it's Neville Longbottom show some
respect
so I would really suggest watching
Deathly Hallows Part 1 right before you
watch Deathly Hallows Part 2 because
like I said this movie starts right
where the last one left off and you see
a couple characters you're like why are
they there again oh yeah that's right
it's ok basically 95% of what I wanted
to see in Deathly Hallows part-2 you was
in Deathly Hallows part-2
it was fun it was exciting it was
emotional it was actually sad it hits
most every emotion you can think of or
want in a movie especially the movies
rating which is awesome tacular
I can say purest type fans of the book
you know people who don't like things
being altered will be like yeah the
movies great and fans of the movies who
haven't read the books will be like yeah
the movies great
so everyone wins the only thing is how
it wraps up after such an exciting like
two hours you leave a movie theater and
you just you just kind of gets sad it's
over it sucks as it's over in fact no
here it is here's the thing that
bothered me this is me being petty so
full of the more yellow you know the one
from the trailer
he didn't do it in the movie like at all
he might have done like a half a one
once
other than that no there it is that
disappointed me false advertising in
trailers so what's your favorite Harry
Potter movie or favorite Harry Potter
book or book versus movie comment below
let me know and if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more expense oh yeah
look at that mine now